dear past me I know it's been a while
but it's because I've been trying to
grow and get better and I know things
are hard for you right now no matter how
hard you try you just can't seem to make
mom happy and I know Mom says some
really hurtful things to you sometimes
and you feel like you deserve it and you
know you get angry at yourself a lot
you're frustrated and you feel like
you're worthless so you tell yourself
that all the time but I promise you
you're not worthless don't forget that
you can always ask for help even if it's
just somebody to talk to
you've been told that you should believe
and listen to everything your parents
say but nobody is perfect so sometimes
they make mistakes
and sometimes they hurt themselves and
hurt you and all because they're trying
to love you but don't know how and I
want you to know that I still love mom
and I've come to terms with the fact
that she may never understand the kind
of pain she's made me feel I wish mom
would realize that she
serves to love yourself too there's
little I can do I'm not as close with
her anymore but that's okay because some
relationships work better at a distance
even if you're born into it and it's
gonna be hard but we'll get better I
promise because at the end all you need
to do is love yourself and be kind to
yourself allow yourself to grow I want
you to know that I love you and you
should love you too I know you're gonna
do great
[Music]